humor has to be relatable feminist it
has to
exist in reality you can't just make
[ __ ] up damn it
okay now it's time for everyone's
favorite series try to laugh where i
watch feminist comedians and try to find
a joke any joke that's worthy of of of
laughter now i say that this is
everyone's favorite
series but i should say everyone minus
one because it's not really
my own favorite right now i'm acting
like this is fun this series for me has
been a
source of great sorrow and suffering and
pain
on a personal level that i've inflicted
on myself don't try to stop me
so anyway so far to recap we have um
watched
and failed to laugh at samantha b hannah
gatsby
chelsea handler and the other one i
forget her name
it's been a murderer's row of shrill
unfunny harpies i'm hoping that today
we finally find a funny feminist
comedian i'm feeling pretty good about
it we now turn to
ali wong okay ali wong is according to
wikipedia
an american comedian actress and writer
she has noted for her netflix stand up
specials baby cobra and hard knock wife
both of which received critical acclaim
critical acclaim that's a good that's a
good sign
that makes me optimistic surely the
critics would never acclaim something
that is bad so today we're gonna we're
gonna
try to do this we're gonna make it easy
netflix themselves on youtube has
compiled
on their channel a video which they say
is the best the very best of ali wong
and uh we'll start with that let's watch
so i don't know if you guys can tell but
i
am seven and a half months pregnant
yeah it's
very rare and unusual to see
a female comic perform pregnant
because female comics don't get pregnant
just try to think of one i dare you
there's none of them
once they do get pregnant they generally
disappear that's not the case
with male comics once they have a baby
they'll get up on stage a week
afterwards
and they'll be like guys i just had this
baby
that baby's a little piece of it's so
annoying and boring
and all these other dads in the audience
are like that's hilarious
i identify and their fame just swells
because they become this relatable
family funny man
all of a sudden meanwhile the mom is at
home
chapping her nipples feeding the baby
and wearing a frozen diaper because her
needs to heal
from the baby's head shredding it up
she's busy
this is the best of ally wong right let
me check again was it the worst
no no it's the best okay all right look
well first of all i you know i have
watched a lot of male comics in my day
and many of them you know make jokes
about parenthood fatherhood
i have never heard any of them say my
baby is a little piece of
i have i've never maybe louis c.k has
come the closest
to that kind of thing but generally this
is not something
that male comics are saying and i know
it's a joke you could say well she's
just making a joke but
in order for jokes to be funny it has to
bear
some relation to things that really
occur in the real world otherwise it's
not funny
you see second this woman is literally
just screaming at the audience
and she seems like she's gonna cry and
the thing is that should be funny right
there's
it's it's it is very funny and it's one
of my favorite pastimes is to is to uh
laugh at feminists as they scream and
cry it's a very very funny sight
and i and i appreciate it as much as the
next guy believe me but um
somehow this one is doing it and she's a
comedian
and yet she's failing to be funny in the
process it's kind of amazing
in fact it's so sexist when people ask
me well
if you're here then who's taking care of
the baby
who the do you think is taking
care of the baby
the tv is taking care of the baby okay
i'm just waiting for the right moment to
like become a housewife
financially you know i want my husband
to get us to like a certain point
financially i want to get to the point
as a couple
where i can comfortably afford sliced
mango
i'm talking about i'm talking about that
whole foods mango that 10
a box whole foods mango that was sliced
by white people that's the kind of
income bracket
i'm striving for that's when you know
you've made it
when you're eating mango that was sliced
by a dude named
noah i want noah mango rebecca kiwi
danielle pineapple i have to admit that
this
joke in its specificity is going over my
head a little bit and
i you know i've been inside of a whole
foods maybe twice in my entire life
i'm also not a big mango guy so i'm not
familiar with the mango culture
tommy needs a mango maybe if you're a
big whole foods
fan and an avid mango enthusiast this
material is just killer maybe
this is the best of ali wong the bit
about mangoes and maybe if you're a big
mango person
you you've never heard anything funnier
than this it's possible that's possible
but the game here is to make me laugh
and uh i am not laughing
sadly if you are hiring
a 25 year old pretty young thing to be
your nanny
you a dumbass
do you not read people magazine you
don't know what's up that's inviting a
marriage grenade into your home
when you have a newborn baby your
marriage is very weak because you're
both stressed out
you look like because you don't shower
no more you're resentful of each other
whose idea was it to bring this new
roommate into the world
your marriage is very vulnerable and
easy for an outsider to invade
and colonize
if we had hired a 25 year old
man who was
not ugly
great with my daughter and said yes
immediately
to every chore i asked him to do with a
positive
attitude
or you best believe that i would eat
the sh out of his butthole
[Applause]
so i'm glad we could hear this well glad
is a strong word maybe a wrong word more
um
i think you're about one step away from
cutting your ear off repulsed
probably is what i'm going for wishing
that i had woken up this morning with
catastrophic hearing loss so i wouldn't
have had to hear any of that there's
probably more of them feeling but since
we're here
this is a learning opportunity and this
is exactly why
so many female comedians are frankly
really really terrible it's because
they're so impressed with their own
vulgarity right they're so impressed
with the fact
that uh that they can say bad words and
and so
they think the audience is just gonna
laugh at the vulgarity itself
just for its own sake unfortunately as
this audience proves
some people especially those with iqs uh
around the same
vicinity as say you know a small
woodland creature like squirrel level iq
people
they actually will laugh at the very
fact that a woman
said it said something dirty you know
that lady said naughty word
me laugh it funny naughty word
funny like that's that's the the thought
process
for the morons in the audience there but
for the more discerning comedy audience
that's not enough
of a punchline we need you to actually
say something that is funny we need the
vulgarity in a funny context and the sad
thing is
in this case she was actually setting up
maybe
it's like she was getting ready maybe to
say something funny and poignant but at
the very last moment
right on the cusp of almost saying
something clever and witty
she veered right into a butthole and uh
which is not where you want to be
so we got so close ended up in the
butthole let's keep watching
every day every day would be an all-day
nanny butthole buffet okay we're still
talking about buttholes here
let's um let's try to move on we're
gonna try to get past
there's quite a lot there's quite a lot
of the butthole material by the way
we're gonna try to move past it
and get somewhere else and we'll try
uh we'll try here let's listen i have
been ruminating
a lot over this one time i hooked up
with this dude
and in the middle of kissing i
felt the responsibility to stop and say
hey i should really let you know
now before we go any further that
i'm on my period
and he was like oh well
then let's make a mess ally
to this day that is the most
romantic thing anybody
has ever said to me
i'm so regretting uh my life choices as
always when we do these things
we've gone from buttholes to periods
yeah let's go i'm so nasty
she's got the scatological humor down
not the humor part necessarily but she's
got scatological she's got that part
like she she's figured out how to
talk about those topics she hasn't
figured out how to say anything funny
about her bodily functions but she can
talk about them she's noticed
that she has bodily functions and she
can say a lot of stuff about it
so she's got that at least you got to
give her that right
and by the way humor is all about
subverting expectations it's all about
uh you know
giving us the unexpected coming at
something from a different angle
but with this joke like like always you
knew exactly where it was going
you knew exactly what she was going to
say you know the punch line if we can
even call it that
and that's the problem with with almost
all feminist comedy i know exactly where
it's going
and most of the time it's going into the
pants
somewhere and finding nothing funny to
talk about
down there against all odds for some
reason we're going to keep watching
clips let's continue
my husband and i were trying to have a
kid a lot of people
were like oh my god that's so hot you
guys doing a lot of fun
no dude that's that's you do in your 20s
okay
uh just no they didn't nobody said that
to you ever
that definitely didn't that's not what
anyone says
not one person ever in history has
responded that way to the news
that someone is trying to have a baby
there's never been a time
you know when you say i'm trying to have
a baby another person goes oh god that's
so hot
if someone said that to you you'd be
like what dude are you are you
what kind of pervert are you get the
hell out of my house i never should have
invited you to thanksgiving
that's the way it would go but it
doesn't go that way because that's that
never
happens and you see you see humor has to
be relatable feminist it has to
it has to exist in reality you can't
just make shut up damn it
it's frustrating to me say something
that
that is related to the world that we
live in
can you do that
killing me with this i don't want to
live anymore okay
keep going when you're in your 30s and
you've been trying to get pregnant for a
while it gets
very clinical you pee on these ovulation
strips
that tell you when the eggs are dropping
it tells you when it's easter time
and i would only [ __ ] him when it was
easter time
okay you know i'm really wondering if
this woman
has any jokes at all that first of all
are jokes
and second that have anything to do with
any topic
other than her having sex with guys
maybe it's just at this point
she just the idea is to spew out hours
and hours of sex jokes hoping that
as a matter of sheer statistical
probability
one of them will eventually be funny but
it's not working
so let's skip ahead and see we're almost
at the end of the video is there
will will we ever get to another topic
let's uh let's keep watching
and then i would jump on him and hold on
to his neck and i would just
twerk twerk twerk that [ __ ] out of him
and do some of this [ __ ] that i learned
in atlanta
no that's it that's really it it's uh
that's
that's that's actually all she has
that's the entire
montage of the best of this woman and
that's all it is
i have to say you know what i honestly
watching this this is the overwhelming
feeling that i have i feel deeply
sad i really do i'm really sad right now
like have you ever had the experience
where you see someone out in public
and maybe some sort of lonely looking
person eating alone at a restaurant or
something on a friday night
and you you get this sense of pity
just oh it's it it overcomes you and you
see this person you feel you feel so
sorry for them
and you don't even know them you want to
walk up to them and pat them on the
shoulder and say
it's gonna be okay buddy it's gonna be
okay but you don't do that because you
know that
it would you know they would probably
look at you like you're insane
and then say something like dude my wife
is just in the bathroom she'll be back
in a second what are you doing you're
weirdo
you know what i'm talking about maybe
you don't know maybe this is my mango at
whole foods moment where this is totally
unrelatable to you
but anyway i almost gave my point i
almost get that sense
um with ali wong here almost
except that my pity is mixed with
revulsion
and annoyance and what i really want to
do
is instead is walk up to her and pat her
on the shoulder and say ally
please shut the hell up you're really
annoying
and you're embarrassing yourself none of
this is funny
i'm sure you have talents i'm i'm sure
you do
comedy is not one of them
that's a talk she needs from someone an
intervention that she needs maybe this
video will do it maybe that's uh maybe
i'll have done some good in in the world
turn this tragedy into a triumph in a
certain way
but what i can't do is turn it into
comedy because there's no humor here
there's only sadness and desperation
and buttholes a lot of those